i think the big makeup blunder that is
just ingrained
in my brain for forever now is the shape
of water
when that got overlooked wow i just like
yeah you know
i couldn't compute that well it's funny
because there are
you know there are unique rules
that they have to abide by and one of
them is is that they don't want
uh shows that are augmented digitally um
and i think because you know listen i
mean you know mike hill and the guys
that that actually built that suit
did an amazing job but because the eyes
were
digital and the blink was augmented
i do feel that that's uh ultimately ends
up being a bit of a gray area
with with makeup artists because you
have to
sit back and go was that makeup or is it
a visual effect or what
what exactly is it and i know for
example when they do these sort of
bake-offs and they
determine who's going to get the final
nomination
they really don't want to see
makeups that have been digitally
augmented because
they want it to be um solely the
accomplishment of the makeup artist and
the hairstylist yeah that's
fair but but listen that's not to say
that there's
hasn't been um hundreds and hundreds of
films that had been
worthy of a nomination that didn't and
you know you always get the
the snubs and uh you know you know we
we uh are we worked on suicide squad
and one of the you know we that film won
an academy award for best makeup
and the makeup artist that won was a guy
that we had brought in to
apply the killer croc makeup but you
know they look at the
overall you know like the straight
makeup
all the hair all the styles all the
tattoos all that kind of stuff so
you know there's a lot that goes into it
you